P butter P juice and bagel in a glass
oh and pot heads Vsauce Kevin here this
is mind blow
what's tougher a Super Nintendo
cartridge or Genesis well it turns out
you can freeze drop and boil both and
they'll still be playable so pass the
jello that's not how you burn a CD whoa
CD bubble it works best with the plastic
divider in a pack of CDRs but the
results are kind of condoms let's talk
video game covers as classics these are
reimagined game covers in the style of
novels including gta4 star crab and
Mario Kart dude a hotel in Japan is
building a neon genesis evangelion room
complete with entry plug bed and Rey
Ayanami wake up calls for only 450 bucks
a night so instead you can watch
Evangelion inside your head with this
iPhone hat just put your iPhone in the
front look through the magnifying glass
and look like an idiot you can buy
clouds Buster Sword from Final Fantasy 7
complete with materia slots but what I
really was Mega Man's Megabus sir here's
a cool schematic now someone please
intentness scientists did recently make
a paper clip invisible using a naturally
forming crystal called calcite in a
backyard evil scientist built a solar
death ray
using an old satellite dish and 5,800
tiny mirrors this thing can burn through
steel aluminium and concrete
and probably 153 clothes pegs which is a
painful world record a new gaming world
record was set when this girl scored
seven hundred eighty nine thousand three
hundred and forty nine points I'm
draggin forces through the fire and
flame Guitar Hero 3 so it begs the
question what's your favorite song to
play on guitar hero or rock band I'm
going to leave you guys with the riddle
the first person to get the real right
and explain how they got their answer
will be featured at the top of the
sauces channel page as our genius of the
week since you can't smoke the entire
cigar hang collects cigar butts and can
make a cigar out of every five butts
that he finds he has collected 25 cigar
buds how many cigars will he be able to
smoke I think you know it leave your
answer in the comments below and as
always thanks for watching